damit der dampf in hollywood
wasser hat vorjahr
sogar zwölf minuten
murat ernsthaft so herzlich willkommen
in murats fünf minuten und zwar heute
passiert was gigantisches und zwar
werden wir heute kochen auf bildungs auf
geringem bildungsniveau in einer
stresssituation machen
das heißt ich werde mehrere sachen
gleichzeitig machen und zwar das
schwierigere sein
ich mag das nicht alles irgendwie
durcheinander ist am heute ist irgendwie
alles auseinander weil meine frau ist
mit in der küche während ski und ich
backen macht meine frau hier spaghetti
essen 15 leute das ganze team die hocken
da drin
die nerds und die die machen was ein
computer keiner weiß was sie machen aber
sie machen es gut und meine frau macht
jetzt für die jungs hier was macht
käselaibe nudeln käse leid und
währenddessen werde ich einen kleinen
bakken und zwacken auf geringem
bildungsniveau der grüne hat ungefähr
das bildungsniveau eines kanadischen
fischotters deswegen habe ich ihn
eingeladen da wir ja auch wirklich merkt
das ist wirklich jeder machen kann
der kuchen ist für das ganz ganz
besonderes es ist ein halt dich fest
also ich fest zauber kuchen
das besondere zauber cohen der ist
wirklich schwer zu machen man braucht da
wirklich eine gewisse man braucht eine
gewisse fachkenntnisse aber damit ja
wirklich merken dass sich jeder machen
kann habe ich heute wieder euren grigny
dabei und zwar wenn ich da würde ich
hier zu mieten eines kanals fischer
sonst habe ich alle jene rein und mache
ich jetzt ganz ganz tolle sache
würdest du bitte aufhören wir stress zu
machen nicht so laut
so so ich bin die kann man auch mich zu
richten weil hier spielt die musik oder
auf jeden fall welchem ersten
schätzungen anziehen so schützen schütze
wieder das ist keine kinder schütze sein
wir haben uns gefragt auf der bühne groß
ist ist dann wirklich bist echt groß
genug
wieso auch aber große leute fallen tief
deswegen ja aber fangen wir mit den
zutaten und zutaten tippen
die zutaten sind heute auch ganz ganz
besonders und zwar haben wir hier vier
glückliche eier dann haben wir hier eine
prise salz die brauchen wir nach etwas
einstieg genau dann haben wir hier 75
gramm zucker dann haben wir ein halbes
presse warum der hinweis dass jemand
genau ich hatte eigentlich schon
gedruckt haben nur einen halben liter es
besser können wir auch nehmen wenn wenn
wenn wenn kinder das essen
die nudeln springen toll hinterlegen
nach knoblauch halben becher espresso
aufnehmen das macht nichts aus auch in
verbindung mit ritalin macht das nix so
dann haben wir hier ein extrakt da
könnte ja ein teelöffel nehmen dann
haben wir butter und zwar 125 gramm
das ist keine butter ist margarine über
weiß ich dass ich lasse es margarine ist
muss es nicht
ich vertraue dir dann gehe ich weiß das
weil ich hab's gemacht
dann haben wir hier mail und zwar 70
gramm und 60 km ist wenig denken ja und
dann haben wir hier packt cacau
das ist kein normaler also es gibt cacau
wacker oder gibts auch caracas anderes
dann aber hier alles schon erwähnt dass
wir 75 programmen zu bekommen zweimal
also zweimal 75 gramm zucker 750 gramm
machen
die nächste idee wenn so was meine krieg
passiert dann macht mir das einfach so
wie die queen
so jetzt haben wir noch kein 70 kam
sogar auf jeden fall da haben noch milch
und zwar milch haben wir hier 500
milliliter 5 milliliter nicht so fünf
milliliter und haben auch hilfe brauche
nachher irgendwann erstmals alle als
erstes holen wir uns ein roboter mit dem
roboter stunde die eier trennen und zwar
in zwei helfen
das machen wir nicht das machst du ja
und warum eine schale dieses nichts
vorbereitet ich während ich die schale
holt weiß haben ja zwei schalen während
ich die schale holen
hahaha siehst du was geht läuft wäre
schade hole schauen was die serie macht
sich was machst du gerade
das sind nudeln in granada leib kanada
ist ein ort in italien ist die gegend
ist keine marke eigentlich noch die
magische sollen aber kein käse ich bin
gerade durch einander auf jeden fall
darf man käse der überhalb der poebene
po ist ein fluss in italien was man das
vergessen ich heute noch mal so ich habe
hier zwei schalen und das getränk wie
ein kritisches hinein trennen
ok dann trennen wir die eier durch
geschickte wahnsinn
nicht noch so heiß rainer rahn schießt
mal ein trend ist bei dir bitte auch
gemacht hat gesagt okay ihr merkt der
könig gar nicht gewusst die mülheimer
musst du musst immer aufpassen
warum treffen das eigelb revanchierte ja
weil dies ein modell befinden sich immer
auf der schale oder ungenießbar ist kann
schon auch ganz schön was ist wenn die
menschen bundes nicht einmal
und außerdem kann ich mal gemeinsam mal
gucken kannst du bist ein seriöser
schauen kinder ziehen
er macht das was aus wenn ja jetzt gibt
es einen trick ist ein normal zu retten
das ein was denn das alles was jetzt
kommt
das konnte drin das eigelb oder ja ja
das kann man drin lassen
ich kann mir das drin lassen der grüne
hat der deckungsgrad da hat da hat es
eine rein geschlagener einschließe ja
das ist macht liegt das macht noch 1 1
das kommt wie blöd kann man eigentlich
sein was mach ich jetzt machen wir
unseren teil beitragen
okay wir brauchen eine reihe aus küche
geben natürlich waren wir uns gleich die
hände
ich kann nichts passiert der kann nicht
krank werden
den will ich kann nichts passieren kann
nicht krank werden denn auch viren haben
ihren stolz
okay das ist jetzt angesagt ist echt
ganz nah ich nichts
meine tochter ist sieben jahre alt
ich kann ja besser aufschlag als du so
das war's dann machst du ach so okay
jetzt haben wir ein hoch geschlagen
jetzt holen wir uns einen kopf roboter
hörer wurde ja ich hole ist ein roboter
und schlagen dass ein steif schlagen
kennt sich aus also mit einschlagen
kennt sich aus das ist diesmal anders
eingeteilt war man jetzt mal zwei
schüsseln so jetzt haben wir hier nicht
eine glasschüssel und jetzt sondern das
schlagen von thomas weiß dass ai weiwei
schlagen und zwar natürlich das eiweiß
hier rein und dann nehmen wir noch eine
prise salz um die eiweiß struktur zu
rächen
so und jetzt kann ich das eiweiß steif
schlagen und zwar ein paar minuten
musste das so
ja solange ich das weiß lage juni die
butter erwärmen und die verlief verteilt
in these den blumen oder etwas zu lange
schlägt das gute recht oder personal und
das programm ein schlauer habe ich nicht
dass ich schon in meinem leben kuchen
gebacken ja für mehr wie du
und woran merkt man das ist interessen
sie platt
da war alles probieren und zwar weil wir
das so macht seht ihr das dann kommt
nichts mehr raus dann ist das ding
streit geschlagen oder kriegst auch
nicht immer allein
so also als nächstes machen wie zucker
dazu musste ich doch sagen aber zwei
gemacht und künste darum macht nichts
hauptsache euch geht es gut und er
schmeckt euch während bin ich ja aber
leider war damals bin ich sagen was die
zuschauer die folgen
ja ich möchte konzentriert nein das
macht spaß das macht jetzt das eigelb
und macht lassen butter dazu ist ein ok
und dann - das sind es ist ganz ganz
wichtig ist die bude darf nicht zu heiß
sein weil es solche geräte das eigelb du
darfst die butter nicht dazu machen das
kann mal vorkommen
doch das wird alles sondern und das
rezept hier steht eiweiß mit salz steif
schlagen
alle gemacht ok mit zucker espresso und
salz sehr schnell also ein eigelb zucker
und jetzt ein halbes tor ein lern und
das salz hey wo ich es salz hast du ich
hab es daran gemacht ein bisschen salz
mehl und kakao dazu sieben und
unternehmen damit nimmt das nähen und
machen das was ihn noch fragen
und auch wieder unter wenn man kein
zitat wenn wir nicht schon sie hat dann
nimmt man halt ein anderes ergibt sich
ganz lang und nach und nach unterstelle
ich im hören will ich dazu überhaupt
doch marie de medici brauchst du so
lange die total training war da
irgendwas falsch gemacht wie flüssig
dass ich ein kabarett gemacht
kann es sein er lief ja das habe ich
noch gesagt aber dann werde ich höre
jetzt um beute die sache ist und eine
beleidigte und weiß
währenddessen gegen die assistenten die
heidi die backform reise so wörtlich
weiß unternehmen tätig hohe wellen
geschlagen ist doch so
ja ich habe keinen gefunden dass eben
doch ein kleiner nämlich denn so langsam
unterheben juni nicht zu spüren
die angst wenn sie das aus bundesmitteln
das angehoben haben das heißt unter dem
eigentlich für uns wir haben es unter
gehoben jetzt schauen was passiert und
zwar habe ich gesagt dass ich einen
zauber kuchen und jetzt durch diesen
flüssigen teich da rein und dann packt
er wieder gebacken ist siehst du diese
drei schichten
ok also jetzt muss langsam in die
backform sowie
und dafür wird die keinen kran nehmen
weil das endlich ein extrem flüssiger
teig ist jetzt auch nicht gedacht oder
gar nicht mehr hätte
jetzt nehmen wir diese bugs und uns doch
mal so prof das ist gut verläuft da war
das nicht
und zwar machen wir das im 9
bush mag assistenten und back assistent
heißt folgendes die gemacht den ofen auf
und schieben rein
vielen dank
jetzt lassen wir den backofen laufen und
zwar auf 4 grad und 150 grad zwei
stunden eine stunde 45 minuten 850 grad
55 minuten 150 grad eingestellt und
jetzt warten wir einfach nur noch zeiten
meistern so jedoch die zeit und sagt
dann 55 minuten perfekt 150 grad 55
minuten und privaten so lange und essen
nudeln noch spaghetti und dann schauen
uns an ob aus dem zauber kuchen will ich
etwas wundervolles gefühl was gefördert
haben ja okay was ist in der
zwischenzeit passiert juni hat zwei
teller nudeln gegessen und zweimal in
den bauch anschaue dann hast auch in
paris anlässen so auf jeden fall unser
fokus ist haben wir den kuchen drin
gehabt jetzt haben wir nach 50 minuten
gemerkt nach 50 minuten gemerkt dass wir
noch ziemlich public war und zwar so der
wahlsieger blick das waren wir haben
noch zehn minuten länger drin gelassen
jetzt haben den kuchen raus werden den
abkühlen
und wieder abgekühlt hast dann dann
stütze den kurs jetzt hole ich ihn raus
nicht nur zwei stunden gefühle
er muss zwei stunden kühl oder ich hab
ein trick nicht schneller geht draußen
haben wir minus sechs grad das ist
vielleicht nur 20 minuten
man muss nur wissen wie man es macht
unseren handschuh aja ist lappen
das sind handschuhe st das nehme jetzt
mit raus und lassen es einfach draußen
abkühlen okay du wartest du auch so
lange auf mich nie tut mir einfach
gefallen juni so und ist jetzt raus ich
komme gleich du kannst zwar auch die
geschichte der atomanlage gemacht
erzählten die geschichte die wir uns
kennengelernt habe während seiner ganzen
sache wieder rausgenommen werden lieber
nicht ich halte das nicht
da muss mich immer
[Musik]
so machen einfach mal zwei stunden
draußen wieder abgekühlt ist und dann
mehrere kurs stützen so der kuchen ist
es abgekühlt
juli der fischotter und ich wir haben
den kunden ist gebacken ich weiß ich was
passiert uns war der kugel jetzt aus von
aufsicht und jetzt zu ihnen einfach hier
mit einem messer hier ein bisschen frei
machen und natürlich einstürzen du hast
schon gehört und kuchen stürzte schon
mal gemacht gebeutelt ist aber nicht ich
nehme ich nein
auf jeden fall tun mit den kuchen
stürzen normalerweise störst du dich mal
auf den kuchen jetzt mal anders mit auch
das gehört jetzt hört ein kurzes rucken
und schauen wie der kuchen aussieht so
zieht der kümmert kann vielleicht ein
bisschen puder zugetraut machen das ist
nicht so aussieht dass wir sie sieht das
ist aber jetzt kommen was das was
passiert ich kann zu zeigen
siehst du das hier das logo siehst du
das kann man es sehen
sie ist es und zwar ist es von dieser
bakom haben wir geschafft juni
jetzt hat jetzt unter oder jetzt auf das
ding ist ja in den kurven ist ja das
besondere vor allem zauber kuchen war ja
dass er drei schichten hat obwohl wir
alle zusammen gemixt haben oder das ist
der kreis ist so flach hat mich sehen ob
der wasserschichten der hat aber er
sieht auch blöd aus der kuchen ich
glaube dass sie ist die hose gegangen ja
ich glaub das problem war einfach als da
dran stand man soll den eischnee
unterheben hast du nein gehört habe ich
recht wir haben angehört das hast du
gemacht
hör doch mal ein bisschen mal in die
vergangenheit reisen konnte gucken wie
das ausgeht
das duo nach oben das heißt gut leben
eigentlich
ich habe mir gesagt haben du hast
schnell stellte die mixe du hast mal
immer noch weiter in die vergangenheit
reist junis entstehungsgeschichte und
das ist vielleicht verhindert bin ich
bei dir deine eltern lieber fahren ja
darin spazieren der kokon sie leicht aus
wie sie daraus dann absolut okay lösung
würden ich mache jetzt darüber dass es
nicht so schlecht aussieht
das ist ein alter trick des schäfers
gemacht dass es nicht so schlecht
aussieht sollte würde ich auch noch ein
bisschen drüber sagt okay jetzt war auch
folgendes jetzt kommt man richtig mache
jetzt mal anschneiden und kommen wieder
aussieht wenn ich glaube der irgendwie
haben es sich hingegen auf dem bild sei
es kein anderes auf dem rezept fast zu
schnell
ok 2000 machen wir jetzt einmal
anschneiden gucken ob da auch diese drei
schichten hat und zwar sehen wir so
anschneiden schneider-ammann hier aber
kein messer oder ja richtig erkannt
erfreulich nur prüfen
das ist ein japanisches gemüsemesser
machen wir ganz kurz und gucken wie es
aussieht ob das ding wirklich seine drei
schichten hat der ist irgendwie war
belegt und es hat funktioniert das hat
ja ich glaube da soll es so aussehen
[Gelächter]
und zwar hat der kuchen drei schichten
sehen sie das und zwar ist hier eine
schicht kuchen und dann ist eine schicht
da ich gar nichts da kommt noch eine
schicht kuchen
[Musik]
schmeckt ein schlecht und ich glaube
eines reserve sorgen machen doch du hast
da mitgemacht und nicht so durch den
teig wir werden alles probieren provinz
ich weiß habe ich noch nie gemacht oder
hast du aber irgendwas hat irgendwas hat
was wir wissen und ich war jetzt mal
ohne sprache wir haben wir müssen ein
neues video ein neues video machen
nochmal komplettieren vielleicht ohne
die ich gleich wenig besser hin
ich probiere noch mal er hat irgendwas
assist kam mit irgendwas hatte du hast
auch was gespritzt
der steig aber so schlecht was die
nichterfüllung wird sowie die erfüllung
hinten drin ja komm mal hier drauf war
kurz und ich gebe euch mal und ihr
probiert jetzt aber ganz ehrlich wie
schmeckt okay das hat der könig gemacht
zu probieren
ja
probier mal aber mir ist ehrlich sein
wie schmeckt ja
es schmeckt gefährlich aber auch nicht
so ehrlich weil ich nicht gut geht das
ist probiert probleme hat mit gut man
ist auch ihr müsst aber ehrlich sein
okay hier kam ein schatz probier mal das
schmeckt schokoladen ja ich bin der
schmeckt auch schon ich bin normal
bist du noch mal aber das wenige zu
ehrlich aber irgendwie ist auch cool aus
das ist ja schon drei schichten ja
optimal kommt kannst du doch gucken da
drei schießen sie ist das wofür man
immer was dass der erfinder dieses
rezept nicht wieder dummheit von uns
gerechnet hat ich glaube einfach dass
jemand dieses rezept einfach ein rezept
zusammengestellt hat was falsch ist so
viel flüssigkeit und alles und sich der
teig einfach absetzt und dann hat er
einfach zauber kuchen genannt bei der
teig eine homogene masse gibt sondern
sich beim backen höchst weder lustig
noch wirklich noch und dann einfach
zauber kuchen genannt weil alle
nachmachen
auf jeder macht diesen zauber kuchen da
nach ich bin irgendwann eben was hat er
denn er steckt speck ist schwierig
aha jetzt weiß woher es kommt alles von
ihm weiß wird das wieder gemacht hat sei
der fehler gemacht haben wir können es
wieder in die länge ziehen also macht
den kuchen nicht nach es war das erste
mal eine geschichte von salis welt wo
man gesagt mache es nicht nach aber die
kinder essen aber zu 7
da sieht man dass sie von mir okay auch
wenn man mit aber außerhalb werden in
erfüllung der enthüllung
so schmeckt da ja schon lustig das ist
bei diese creme füllung nach ob
ballaballa luftig kennst dich ja auch
also tschüss macht's gut macht's besser
wir sehen uns dann später noch mal
probiert
[Musik]